- I remember the first time I saw her.
I felt like I'd known her my whole life.
I kinda fell in love with her.
Couldn't wait to see her again and again.
They took her away.
- She showed me what a loving relationship
actually looked like.
I miss her every day.
Not even magic can bring her back.
- When she found happiness,
it gave me hope, you know?
And then it all ended.
(somber violin and piano music)
(swishing)
(squeaking)
- I am affected.
- Since 1976, 65% of all queer
female television characters
have died.
(somber violin and piano)
- According to
autostraddle.com, in 2015 alone,
24 queer female characters
have been killed on television.
- Already in 2016, there
have been 12 deaths.
How many more?
- How many more?
All of them? OK.
- We deserve better.
- So we wanted to give
the writers out there
some more options for their
queer female characters.
- Like, just not killing them, maybe.
- Or you could have that
stray bullet miss them
and hit someone else for a change.
- Give them an identical twin.
- Have them get their master's degree.
That can take them out of a season or two.
- They pull a groin muscle
just from wonderful sex.
- Why not a gay ghost?
- I would love to be haunted by a lesbian.
- Let their spirit live inside a cat.
- Have them go to a carnival.
- They can grow old, and
have a family, and a dog
and sit on a porch and drink iced tea.
I think that would make for great TV!
- Please.
- [All] Stop killing
queer female characters.
- (whispers) I can't do this.
- She's not the same, OK?
(squeaking)
Her marriage is dead.